good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Monday hope everyone had
a fantabulous weekend speaking of
fantabulous hey Jax how you doing I'm
doing okay as you can hear I'm a little
sick so apologies in advance for
sounding so nasally don't know what the
other option is no
um it's just that time of year we were
speaking about it last week it's coming
for everyone and it's come for your neck
yeah it's been a few days of like a
really slow roll out where I'm teetering
on being sick sick so far I just have
like throat pain a little bit Sneezy
today I have a headache too but like I
don't have full-blown sickness yet so
I'm just sort of waiting I mean I did
Stave it off as long as I could with an
amazing chicken noodle soup yesterday
that I made from scratch I saw I didn't
even have broth so I had to like make
the soup with water it was so good so
nourishing my boys were soup boys
yesterday we were a soup house it was
well you know what you need to keep up
that energy keep drinking your soup
because this is the final week of toast
for the year 2022. I can't go down now
her best I can't go down most unhinged
I'll do my best I'm doing my best that's
all I can say but I mean I'm gonna be
drinking a lot of soup that's all I'll
say a lot of soup final episode of the
year are you feeling nostalgic no how
about you
no you know what actually I feel like it
takes me a really long time to get to
this place
um because like content is my job and
people are always talking about burnout
and it's like you put up one video relax
I actually am now officially getting
burnt out and that's not a feeling I
really have because like I have endless
energy and endless things to talk to my
girly about
um but I'm definitely getting burnt out
which is like not something I'm really
like a feeling I get a lot I feel like
people overuse that term yeah we never
use it uh we plan about two proper
vacations each year we didn't do one
this year though so this is the only one
of 2022 and like any every time we have
a vacation coming up it is like so
necessary not only are we like excited
to vacate but we have run ourselves dry
so I feel like after this week we will
be in that place and we just need like
the two weeks off to miss each other
Miss celebrities miss talking like when
it's on vacation I'm I'm going mute like
I'm a mime I'm not speaking when I'm on
break I will not be putting on one
stitch of makeup my eyelashes are
literally falling off but it's the
burnout but it's also we've had like a
huge Q4 you know we had our deer media
move we had my special the end of tour
like it's just been a lot you know so I
feel I feel um excited for the break and
I know that like when we come back we're
just gonna have Like A Renewed Energy
and I think until the end of the week
it's gonna be like classic unhinged
behavior from us you know Delirious
girlies yeah also end-of-year content is
always so fun to really look back and
reflect on the ear I feel like I haven't
done that yet one on the ear in general
two on the year like personally for us
three on the year professionally the
urine toast I feel like this is the week
where we do that so when you said like
are you emotional like no not yet
because I really haven't thought about
the fact that it was our last week yet
but now
will do so you know what I mean
yeah I do I do I do are you gonna miss
2022
yeah I feel like my life operates in a a
series of good years and bad years
that's how I like look at life
um and this was a very good year which
means a bad year is upon me so I don't
know if that's next year
um I hope not but I do know I have a bad
year coming my way
I guess so I don't know it but I saw I
was the one who started that theory and
like but I do feel like this year kind
of broke the mold like because I always
felt like our odd years were good and
our even years were bad but this was a
good even year yeah no I'm not so sure
it's about even odd I just think that's
life like I think life you have good
years and you have bad years right but
it's not supposed to be every other year
no no no so I'm saying it might not even
be next year that's my bad year but a
bad year is on the horizon for sure
okay well enjoy this one while you've
got it enjoy the good times let the good
times roll it's been a fabulous year and
I'm just gonna very much exist here for
now
that's great well we have a great show
for you guys oh my god do we there's so
much content to talk about I know
Claudia and I both watched Harry and
Megan it's the first story like really
it's the only story
then there's more TV news Claudia
watched White Lotus season finale she
will be recapping And discussing her
thoughts I watched a new episode of
Yellowstone and last week's episode two
we'll be recapping my thoughts Claudia
is on season four of Yellowstone so we
need to get an update from mcclurgia
Claudia also watch sex lives of college
girls
I did I did literally the best show on
TV like you cannot tell me otherwise I'm
really excited to watch I actually have
so much on my contemplate I need to
write it down because this always
happens to me my plate run is over and
then I forget everything so here are the
things that I want to watch they're
pretty varied honestly sex lives of
college girls obviously sex lives next
have you heard of this show about the
fleischmann's
yes on Hulu yeah my friends were talking
about it at dinner they said it's so
good and that we would love it okay
then I need to watch Wednesday
yeah I don't know if I'm gonna watch
that it's really not my um
genre like it's not my style I don't
like stuff like that like I know but you
know what I'm sending diapers down your
spine I think that it is objectively
amazing and I want to watch something
really good that everybody is loving
like you know breaking records and I
feel like I could get into it you know I
that's not my genre either but when it's
good it's good yeah
so that I have to wear big shows to
watch Watch Out World wow just a couple
of big girls in their big shows maybe
I'll watch it this week while I'm sick
while I'm sick
I'm so sick
um you're so sick of Nang and speaking
of circuiting today's episode is going
to be fabulous back remote Studio I have
to say there's nothing better than being
together but I kind of love our remote
setup like I don't know the headphones
and like the way I look like I look so
fat and ugly when we record together and
when we record separate like I'm
literally a model yeah I don't mind it
either and I feel as close to my girl as
ever plus you're literally coming here
in 10 minutes so I know the crazy thing
is enjoy the time apart honestly you and
Harry got out of Dodge and I didn't even
come to say bye because I know I'm gonna
see you in like two days
um like I FaceTime Harry now I'm like I
don't even feel sad
yeah you know it's gonna be so fun to
see you and I can't believe it was a
trip I could use a trip to the uh to the
South yeah for a vacation you gotta
start vacating it's supposed to snow
today
that's exciting soup day I know or chili
well it's now it's now a full year of
what I said I would see the snow by
Christmas and another Christmas is
coming and I will not see the snow it's
like two years
it's like no I'm saying it's a year
since I've said that last
yeah so I think you should honestly like
give up on your dreams
not you encouraging me to give up
yeah because if you're if you're not
going to achieve your dreams I think
it's better to give up that's like what
they say don't quit your day job like
live in reality and don't constantly
like mourn the loss of something that's
not gonna happen
Jesus Christ I'm not mourning the lust I
brought it up once I'll never bring it
up again and I didn't stop living and
it's up staying in my apartment okay but
but I do feel like at a certain point
maybe it was a year ago where you
decided to keep blooming where you're
planting you're like I'm not gonna be
chasing after this apartment that
doesn't exist I did
and that's a good feeling and then you
loved your apartment again you had a
little refresh you got the wallpaper you
have my beautiful art
yeah no but it's there's still no
sunlight and not a cloud inside you know
it's good it's never cloudy in Claudia's
apartment no that's true yesterday I um
did not move from my bed I was I had the
longest week of my life I did not move I
think the first time I went outside was
four o'clock to walk Theo and I was
shook to find out it's been raining the
whole day that's like a crazy feeling
when you literally like everyone in the
world well everyone in the state knows
that it's raining and you don't
how did that make you feel
it definitely made me feel like a
degenerate like do you know what I mean
yeah I do that's not your fault it was
it had degenerative behavior in the
words of Claudia you were merely a
victim of circumstance I was merely a
victim of circumstance
by the way let's talk about your
sweatshirt
anybody else on the planet want to know
what the [ __ ] the bar is and why
everyone's wearing this 200 sweatshirt
so are you just like looking at me
because I'm just looking like so
sickening and cool with my the bar
sweatshirt I'm just like an influencer
except that I paid for it yeah no can
somebody explain they're like cool but
they're cool let me tell you let me tell
you my journey to the bar so the bar is
a brand by at Bridget she's an
influencer and that's her Brandon her
brand like makes these sweatshirts that
say the bar but they also make like
dresses and and real clothes it's a good
clothing company it's a clothing company
but these sweatshirts have really gone
viral and I think Bridget like sent them
to all of her influencer friends and and
just like influencers in general and
they like made them cool but I also was
getting this feeling and I'm not one of
those people by the way I fully
purchased yeah let's talk about how much
did you pay for the bar so there was a
sale there was a sale by three get the
fourth free so I was buying two for
myself because I found two colors that I
liked but I was like if I buy just one
more then I've doubled my order so I I
need to look they were all on sale it
really wasn't crazy it was like 200
something dollars for four sweatshirts I
gave one two oh my God I thought you
were gonna say 200 something dollars for
a sweatshirt no officially lost your
goddamn mind total I gave one to Olivia
because I was like if I get a fourth
I'll give it to her I was gonna like you
know leave one in your room for when you
were here because you should my theory
about these sweatshirts is like there's
something like magical about the way
that they fit that was what I was
thinking before I bought it you know how
you're always looking for the perfect
crew neck I personally think like our
merch crew necks are amazing but I was
like I still am on the Quest for like
the perfect crew neck sometimes I don't
want to wear it like if I'm traveling or
something like I don't want to wear my
own brand for whatever reason it's like
obnoxious safety concerns safety
concerns so um I just was getting this
feeling like this sweatshirt was like
magic fit now I'm not sure if it's a
magic fit or it just looks nice because
I ordered them all in size extra large I
didn't even realize that I did that I I
want them oversized but I could have
done a large they probably didn't have a
lot of sizes so I got four extra
sweatshirts so of course they're
oversized and look awesome this one's
been washed already so it's a little bit
smaller but I do think there's something
special about these sweatshirts
now I'm just curious about what bar what
is the bar oh sorry it's the bar
that's the bar
that's what I said yeah so it's the bar
if you're asking me if I know what the
[ __ ] that is no oh wait how was what you
just said different than what I just
said no it's the same thing just about
how you say it
the bar yeah
what did I say that's what you said
I'm just like I was like [ __ ] with
you oh okay okay but like what does that
mean it was my question I don't know I
think we have to have Bridget on the
toast to explain actually I don't think
we need to have this Bridget she didn't
send us sweatshirts about them I'll
continue I'll continue to shop at show
me yourmove.com okay because they send
me free things you know I'll continue to
shop at shopchamel.com or shop.com yeah
anyway we don't even know our new
website it's toastmatch.com
anyways I I fell for for it I was
influenced by everyone and I like it and
now they're the sweatshirts that don't
fit in my closet because I don't have
room so they're the ones that sit oh my
God that is the most relatable thing
you've ever [ __ ] said either one said
sit out on the bench at the end of my
bed so it's the one mine go on my
windowsill
yeah and I don't have like a chair yet
or a couch in my room but once I do like
it's game over a Shay's Lounge so it is
a nice sweatshirt like I would recommend
it I did get them on sale so
I I feel good about that
yeah but she's got a nice thing going on
the bar
fabulous fabulous and I'll take more
even though I have four I went from
being someone who had zero to someone
who had four
um well I had a kind of traumatizing um
experience this morning you know my
favorite flowers in the world are lilies
and nobody knows that I didn't know
really yeah
I love the smell I don't even like the
way they look so much I love the way
they make your house smell so I was at
Brian's house and he had lilies and I
was like oh my God I love these lilies I
love the way they smell and then for my
special I'm sorry am I boring you
blowing my nose off camera
okay okay thank you
um and listening still you're special
Brian sent lilies to my house and was
like good luck and then today I was like
I really want to take good care of them
so I was cleaning and watering and I
forgot that those little shits inside
the Lily will stay in the [ __ ] out of
anything you owed so my favorite
sweatshirt that I'm wearing right now I
got big yellow piss stains on it I'm so
mad
I'm going in with my hydrogen peroxide
doesn't work yeah it's like one of the
five things in the world that will not
remove
like well that will stain permanently
I'm so annoyed if only Billy Mays
thought of that
rest in peace Billy Mays rest in peace
well I love your sweatshirt you're
looking like a proud American
and I'm looking like a proud influencer
oh my God we are literally like American
influencers American influencers If That
Ain't Us
no that's like the tick tock sound you
know what my pronouns are proud American
that's bugging you today
no the bar my pronouns are the bar
and you know what I will respect that
and I will respect yours
what a great show there's just so much
to dive into I feel like we're Dilly
dallying like everyone's like shut up
and start talking about Harry and Megan
and I just want to say I'm ready to
shock the world with my Harry and Megan
Tate because you know me and like I'm
trying to be better but like I am an
absolute hater to my core like I will
hate everything about like things that
people love you know
um so I was I was ready to go in and
like nitpick the [ __ ] out of it but when
I tell you
um I really I got carried away by their
love story like I really did like I
don't know what they were about what
they were selling but I was buying
everything like I
I just I didn't see that I didn't see
that for myself yeah I think people
might be surprised by some of my
thoughts too actually
and I'm surprised by other people's
thoughts because for the most part the
reaction that I've been seeing is like
oh my God Harry and Megan are so fake
like I liked them before but like people
have really been reacting negatively to
it yeah and to them specifically and I'm
like wow I'm always like thinking that
they're so fake but I was like no yeah
it was like Opposite Day
okay let's get into it without further
Ado
for the
fifth to last time this week here are
the fast five stories that you need to
know
today's episode is brought to you by
PayPal honey thanks to Honey manually
searching for coupon codes this holiday
season is a thing of the past honey is
the free shopping tool that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best ones that it finds to your cart
when you check out the honey button will
drop down and all you have to do is
Click apply coupons wait a few seconds
as honey searches for coupons you can
find for that site if honey finds a
working coupon you'll watch the prices
drop you can add honey to your iPhone
now too just enable it on your Safari
and you can find savings on the go I
have had tremendous success with honey I
have saved money on makeup on
electronics on food on clothing
literally everything most of the places
that I love to shop work with honey and
it's so fabulous and it's so easy
um the fact that you can now download it
on your iPhone too is stunning and so
easy if you don't really have honey you
are straight up missing out on holiday
deals it is that time of year where
we're all doing our last minute chopping
a lot of it is being done online on your
phone on the go and so if you're just
not downloading the browser extension
from honey you're just wasting time
money and everyone's energy and I don't
think you want to be that person so go
get honey and leave a link where you can
get it for free it's free installs in
just a few seconds by getting it you're
doing yourself a solid we would never
recommend something we don't use we've
been using honey for years before they
started sponsoring the show
um and you can get PayPal honey for free
at joinhoney.com toast that's
joinhoney.com
t-o-a-s-t join honey.com slash toast
today's episode is also sponsored by
let me build
your bedroom deserves a refresh and now
is the perfect time to elevate the most
important room in your home with thuma
introducing the bed by thuma it's
handcrafted from eco-friendly high
quality upcycled wood you'll find
beautiful unique variations in the
natural grain the minimalist design
features Japanese joinery and it helps
Elevate any space it's super supportive
for your mattress it's breathable and
it's made to naturally minimize noise
and create space the perfect platform
bed just got even better you can now
customize the bed by choosing between
the original pillow board and the new
solid wood headboard the fabric pillow
board adds softness it adds color to any
space while the headboard offers solid
Sleek support the headboard attaches
directly to the bed using Japanese
joinery with no tools required you can
buy it with the bed or on its own as an
upgrade okay so thuma beds arrive in
three easy to maneuver boxes the way
that they're set up it's Japanese
joinery it will take you five minutes
actually you will not have to divorce
your partner you'll have a gorgeous bed
and you will maintain 11 respect for
your partner that normally doesn't
happen when setting up bedroom furniture
along with the bed thuma offers other
bedroom Essentials to elevate bedtime
the mattress save the nightstand the
side table and they're all perfect
compliments to the bed Jackie's guest
room in her house has the bed I have
slept in it multiple times as has the
snatchler and if it's natural or
approved I've taken I've taken a nap in
there it's right next to the studio it's
pretty much good enough for any old
American you know create that feeling of
checking into your favorite boutique
hotel suite but at home with the bed by
thuma now go to thuma.co toast to
receive a 25 credit towards your
purchase of the bed plus free shipping
in the continental US go to thuma.co
toast that's t-h-u-m-a dot Co slash
toast for 25 credit
thank you mclartiel
you are welcome okay our first story
princess so the new trailer for part two
of Harry and Megan has dropped and the
pull quote is Harry saying the that they
you know the palace quote were happy to
lie to protect my brother but weren't
willing to tell the truth to protect us
ooh well that's interesting because I
think and maybe why a lot of people
didn't like the documentary is because
they didn't really go after the family
at all in the first one like the only
time they really even mentioned them was
when she was talking about how I'm a
hugger and I didn't even think that was
that damaging because that actually is I
think like
I could totally see that being like uh
like a reason why they all got off on
the wrong foot like Megan being like
classically American and British people
being very put off by that British
people are very put off by like American
emotional like distress I don't think
that's caught I think that's like a
relatable story that she shared but I
don't think that's cause for getting off
the wrong foot I don't think that they
would be offended that she tried to hug
them I think it's just like an awkward
stilted moment but not like a grave
insult by any means and just like
actually what I could see I could see
like I feel like this happens all the
time like I could see like
members of the royal family kind of
looking down on her for being like that
that type and then her growing resentful
that they looked at like I think it
could be the starting point of like a
negative relationship
not over a hug I really really don't
think so no not a hug but like a general
sentiment like that's how she was she
said I'm like very American
okay well anyways the first three
episodes of the show dropped it goes all
the way up until the wedding and
I have so many thoughts overall I
enjoyed it much more than I thought that
I would I found them to be more likable
than I've ever found them to be yes
before there were a few inconsistencies
and things that
are a bit hypocritical like I feel like
even one the fact that there's a show at
all you know like of course when she
first said like when they say why are
you doing this and she said when the
stakes are so high doesn't it make sense
to come from us I'm like yeah that's why
you guys did Oprah like what's right
what's this then you know you know
that's fair but I think the biggest
takeaway from the first three episodes
is how in love they are how much of a
love the match this is but I think
anyone would have had to think that they
were that in love to begin with because
you don't cut yourself off from like go
through this so many people that you
love for someone that you're not sure
about like I think that they you have to
be so in love to do what they did and
and feel so dependent and um trusting of
your partner
for yes for me like my takeaway was like
oh my God they're so in love and it's
not like cringe like it's actual like
love but also like for me I was left
with like this deep sadness that it
didn't work out because when they showed
and there wasn't a lot of footage for
What from when Megan was like a working
Royal when they had gotten engaged and
she did the walkabouts and stuff
I feel like
it sucks that it didn't work out because
I feel like she was exactly what the
family needed and she was very good at
it and I know she said she was like
putting on a face and I did find it
shocking her like there wasn't this like
introductory course into how it would be
how to be a royal like they don't sit
you down and tell you what to do like
they just throw you in there
um and I found that interesting but
overall I was just like damn like this
could have worked out if it did and it
would have been so good for everyone
yeah I thought Harry said it best when
he was like in you know deciding to be
with Megan like I chose with my heart
and then in seeing her you know uh and
the way that she is like I also chose
with my head because she's perfect for
the role so the way I'm left feeling
after watching the first three episodes
is this girl is perfect for this
situation
no totally like she was what they needed
she's so that type like you know um nice
like and just like she has this way
about her and that was like really one
of my takeaways like obviously she's a
beautiful woman but like honestly seeing
like all these pictures of her and like
uh like she's literally like the most
beautiful woman in the world and it's so
crazy because she was like a low-level
actress and she was still like the most
beautiful woman in the world and like
now that she's a princess like we all
see it but like you know what I mean
like you would think like someone that
striking you know getting on TV like
they would have blown up into like this
A-list and she really like she wasn't
and she even said like I don't even like
acting yeah I mean maybe if she had
continued with suits and then whatever
was after suits like maybe she would
have eventually gotten there but at the
time that she started dating Harry she's
just like this cable
actress actress I thought what was so
interesting and felt really true was
that the biggest hurdle the family had
in her being the one for Harry was that
she was an actress and I feel like
I I see that I feel like we all felt
that it's like
there's something like so taboo about no
tacky and and about not even acting in
general because I feel like if she was
on Broadway it would have been different
like there's something so talking about
Hollywood Hollywood yeah
no I thought that was interesting too
yeah but I also think like her role as
an actress and her ability to act is a
strength in this role like sometimes
you're doing a walkabout and you don't
want to [ __ ] be there and you've got
to play the part and I think having an
acting background isn't the worst place
to come from
I completely agree
um
and so when we just saw all that footage
I was like damn like I don't even
remember that time I feel like it all
happened so fast I don't remember the
time when she was like like a working
Royal like I really don't remember no
especially because I wasn't invested in
the royal family until like Midway
through their relationship because I
hadn't watched the crown yet like when
they got engaged I did not know that
they were dating I did not I never
watched suits I don't think I knew who
she was
I did not know who she was either but
like I was they were like oh she's a
girl from Suits I'm like oh okay like I
knew what suits was because Olivia likes
suits a Margo and Olivia love it yeah so
all that was all really interesting
um one of the other things that I loved
was learning about the early days of
their relationship because to me I woke
up one morning and they were engaged but
to them they had a year and a half
relationship beforehand so it's like how
do you start a relationship with someone
who's so high profile where do you go
how do you keep it under the radio how
do you actually get to know each other I
feel like that trip to Botswana was so
like that makes or breaks a relationship
and for the any relationship Royal or
not
if you know someone for one month and
you go away for them in a situation
where you're sleeping in a tent together
and like not showering like is there a
toothbrush I don't know
um no I was thinking about that there's
nowhere to run and hide and if you still
love each other at the end of that trip
like you will
be together for a very long time
agreed I found the logistics to be
incredibly interesting and like how
really Megan was the one who had to make
it work because like Harry couldn't just
like fly around Megan because was like
relatively unknown she could fly on
commercial flights and like go see him I
found the logistics of it to be
incredibly interesting and I also found
it interesting how like I don't know why
but I just assumed like these people
didn't have iPhones yeah but like the
way they had like so many pictures and
videos even from the engagement like I
don't know why I felt like they operated
in like a totally Wireless like cut off
from the world like even Harry's saying
he found her on Instagram like he has
his own like private page like Snapchat
to be shocking I found it I it was a
Snapchat filter and that's what I was
saying when we got the first trailer
like we're already seeing all these
pictures of them like in normal people's
situations and we never see like we
never see you know William with the
Snapchat doggy filter on though I'm sure
like it exists and it's a really
it's like seeing a fish out of water
it's it's it's crazy to see them in such
normal contexts
you know what somebody and not somebody
I I did see people like being very put
off by the fact that they had like video
footage from the moment they left like
during the exit
um and I definitely was like oh that's
so weird that like your first instinct
would be to film something
um and they addressed they were like a
friend of ours suggested we started a
video diary because like this is you
know a major moment and it's something
we would want to remember but that
definitely made me like
um you know yeah that's sus especially I
don't think we've seen the footage yet
from that moment we saw a little bit and
what we saw was like not worth recording
like him at the airport being like it's
go time and then her sitting in Canada
just like being in distress and not
saying anything
can I tell you had like people are
really saying like that they came off so
poorly and
you know what
I actually think I agree that Harry came
off poorly like Harry kind of sucks does
anybody else agree like he said kind of
a weenie and he's like a little mean
like I don't know when Megan talks she's
like sitting there like laughing like
hey like being cute and funny he's just
like staring at her oh I didn't feel
that way I've never I just felt like
I've never heard him speak for this
length of time and so I actually it's
not surprising but he is like really
well spoken because he's really yeah
educated and I just like assume he's a
doofus but no he can speak for himself
and I he's just like so enhamed with his
wife like even though I guess he doesn't
find her as funny as she finds herself
but like that's so so respectful towards
her like
I don't know he like I didn't really
like him like
I just but you know what I did really
respect and appreciate how they talked
about the Nazi thing
yeah I mean they have to because nobody
talks about that no I didn't think that
they had to like I think they could have
gotten away with it no not if they were
oh I did talk so heavily like about
racism racism yeah and then that was
just [ __ ] weird
totally I guess they were trying to show
he's like been you know reformed like
yeah reform thank you for the word yeah
um
so you and I were speaking about this
last night and actually after we spoke
about it I was like oh my God she's
totally right
that and you can verbalize it better
than me but like it really felt like for
the short time period of time that they
were working Royals and they were like
this dynamic duo they were actually
making a difference like oh so yeah
that's what so much of the first three
parts was about like their dedication to
service and charity and how that's what
they are driven by and like it was just
like the Selena documentary like I act
so that I can spend a month in Kenya
giving back and I and that's also what
brought Harry and Megan together like
it's such a big part of who they are and
then so I was watching some of the stuff
they did as working Royals and then we
also see some of the stuff that they're
doing now is like
so we're working Royals and they I think
they would have made such more a a much
bigger difference if they stayed in the
royal family like there's so many
opportunities to do service and like
your presence to people means so much
like watching them as
defunct Royals go to like a an American
Air Aviation base in New Jersey to go
and talk to like I don't know what was
it 20 people who wanted to show up and
talk to them and everyone's wearing
masks like it was so painful and it's
like who are these people who are just
coming to our base to talk to us like he
served right in the UK like she like
they are just regular people like
citizens could I walk into that base and
expect some sort of special treatment
everyone wants to talk to me like every
time they do something now I'm like who
cares why you why are you there you're
so right and like I guess they probably
know that you know they would have had
more of an impact
staying and for whatever reasons they
they didn't do that but you're right
like watching the footage of their their
work here in America it felt like it
paled in comparison to like the actual
impact like that footage of them going
to the memorial service for the black
man who was killed by like a gang of
five white guys like that was like
actually impactful and that was really
moving and I think the documentary did
an amazing job of like really explaining
like how big of a deal that was yes and
how much of an impact it made on like
the UK black community and I just felt
like that's huge and like that's why her
being there was like so historic and
like so meaningful to so many people and
and I'm sure we'll find out soon why
they couldn't but like I part of me my
takeaway from the documentary was like I
wish they stuck it out
oh that's been that's my takeaway so far
especially since we haven't really seen
things go south yet even she talked
about their her first Christmas at
Sandringham and she said it was amazing
period like there was except for except
for that woman who wore the brooch but
Megan didn't say anything about that in
the documentary I I don't recall her
like they they talked about it they had
other people talking about it they had
like the beauty clips and the tweets but
we never heard from Megan like I had the
most amazing time at Sandringham and
then I saw that like and and how did
that and what happened how did that
actually said something yeah what was
the response like within the family like
did Megan feel like that what was her
interaction with that woman had she
noticed it while she was there did she
feel like that you're totally right they
like left that
what what happened inside
I don't know they didn't tell us who the
[ __ ] was that woman too
you know some some lady some irrelevant
ugly yeah
oh my God that would by the way that was
crazy yeah um overall I felt like the
documentary did a really fantastic job
of explaining because we're always
hearing about like British media the
British tabloids and honestly I feel
like it's kind of silly because for my
American POV like we don't respect
tabloids like that's like [ __ ] we read
in the airport while we're on the toilet
like it doesn't actually like change
people's hearts and Minds it's not a
part of the Zeitgeist anymore I think
for a while it was
um so I feel like the documentary
actually did an amazing job of
explaining like how the British media
operates like what their role in the
culture is and like why they're so
influential and I found that to be
really helpful because I feel like when
it comes to the Royals we're always like
the media the media the media and it's
just like this like throwaway thing but
I do feel like the documentary did a
good job of explaining how it's
different than in American culture like
it's really a part of the Zeitgeist in
Britain yeah but then I also feel like
like yes and and that's always something
that we've said it's like who cares
about the tabloids but then so much of
it was like
um the media being awful and it's like
well the me like even here like the
media is awful and they are awful two
people and they are like I don't think a
lot of the times like they represent the
the tone of how people are feeling and I
don't know how seriously people actually
take I'm sure there are people who like
take it seriously but like most people
are like
yikes go away yeah and I wonder without
a culture where we question everything
yeah or at least we do but and I worry
about how people in the UK feel where
it's like the tabloids but if they were
I don't know like why would the um royal
family like bring them into the full
work with them yeah yeah
yeah I do yes I did I did give me a
better understanding of that and also
like some of the media stories that
really were so offensive even the stuff
about like her dad
um and and I thought that the thing with
the the niece the long lost niece which
is so interesting fascinating case study
period because it's like this is her
friend it's hard and weird to explain
especially considering she she doesn't
she's not friends with her half-sister
don't talk to her half-sister and the
half-sister's not coming to the wedding
so like that is something that requires
like a long explanation which we get in
this documentary for like me to
understand why the niece would be at the
wedding but considering they don't talk
to the media there's no opportunity to
explain that and instead we would be
like oh she's clearly close with that
side of her family and the sister you
know is right outs
so I just felt like an example like that
was a perfect way of us seeing how like
something could look one way but really
be another way
no and like the way that they had to
uninvite that niece was so sad and like
she's still not over it
yeah and I wonder what their
relationship is now
I know
also so I felt like some stuff was like
a little hypocritical I felt like you
know she was saying that she had no
introduction into Royal ways and Royal
life and I do feel like if I wanted to
go to an etiquette class and learn about
how to do things in real way like I
could book that you know so it's a
little bit like no Jackie your husband
who's a prince could get something to
come to the house right it's a little
bit like taking the initiative but it's
also on Harry to have done that for her
to even I agree no
because she doesn't even know they're
saying she doesn't know so okay why is
she rolling up to brunch with the queen
and he's like wait do you know what a
currency like practice that at home and
maybe there were things that about like
the dress code that maybe he doesn't
know because he's not a woman so I'll
allow that but like yeah
there's so much that he knows that
there's so much protocol and like get
her a teacher I think Diana had teachers
she had like lessons I just assumed that
everyone would but then on the other
hand then they have their Royal
Engagement press moment and she called
that and she was like you know rolling
her eyes at it like it was an
orchestrated reality show and it's like
well they so you mean they tried to
prepare you so that they didn't just
like send you in there not knowing what
you were doing so it's like
you're complaining what do you want get
the prep and then you're rolling your
eyes when you do
no that's a really good point
also it sounds like it really is on
Harry to have been like
let's get I agree
I think in a lot of ways Harry like
failed Megan on the transition yeah and
yes of course like the family should
should but they don't and they they
believe for this like for everyone
coming into the family it's a rite of
passage they've all been through this
like awkward growth transition period
and they didn't want to help her because
they've all been through it and they
feel like you know we did it so you
should do it well not because like oh
you should go through it because we went
through it but because like that's just
how it works you will get to the other
side especially like once you're a
member of the royal family like then
there is that level of respect but it's
like it you just have to go through this
process like that's just how it is not
because like well we're mad so you
should like you should get it too
also they definitely tried to draw like
a lot of parallels between Diana and
Megan and I just want to say like I
actually don't think that they're
similar at all especially like all that
we've found out about Diana now like
through the crown documentaries like
Diana was deeply unwell and Diana really
became crippled under the pressure of
the whole thing and I actually think
even though she didn't get a lot of time
doing it I actually think Megan
maintained like a level of
level-headedness and rationale and she
like really stayed true to herself
throughout the whole thing and she
stayed close with her mom and I think
her mom is so much part of the reason
why she is so level-headed
um so I actually don't think that
they're similar at all no just not
hounded by the media not at all and I I
find those comparisons like kind of
cringe and I feel like that's where
people are like
there's a weird like how are you they're
just like they're they're reaching
there's awareness in those comparisons
and I think the biggest difference
between them and things that really
Illustrated like
who they are and how they've handled the
situation is like Diana came into the
role at such a young age where she
didn't know herself she didn't have like
friends uh that you know the friends
that you have when you're young she had
nobody are they are different than your
adult friends she had nobody and she
also like didn't have a strong enough
sense of self to be able to withstand
all of this like Megan came into this
role and by the way
still a huge role a smaller role than
the role that Diana stepped into because
like you win despair you know William
already had his kid so like yeah you're
you're not going to have to worry about
being Queen one day and she came into it
in her 30s like she not only is she of
age but she is clearly mature for her
age even as a younger person she's so
smart she knows what she wants to do
she's made a life for herself she knows
who her people are like she knows who
she can trust it's so different and I
think that that is like the biggest
factor in in some of the women who do or
don't have success in the family it's
because you need to have you need to
like be a strong enough person before
you join Diana was way too young and to
be with Charles who is older and doesn't
even care like and he's just the worst
but like also and the documentary Megan
not only is making her her own whole
person she has Harry who loves her who
would do anything for her who will
choose her over everyone every single
time where Charles will choose everyone
else over to Ayanna every single time no
and the documentary did a really good
job of illustrating like how full her
life was before this like she had
amazing friends amazing family an
amazing career like she was passionate
she was well traveled and you're right
like I do think she was actually like
primed it was gonna be hard it was going
to be hard no matter what but she was in
like a better position than most women
who entered that family to succeed yes
especially because like the work that
they have you do
some of it is exactly it's work that she
loves that she wants to be doing I think
they also do a lot of Unfabulous work as
the documentary said they do two
thousand to three thousand Royal
engagements a year like a lot of it is
like not even you know the walkabouts
that get photographed it's like no it's
like touring a milk Factor going to mean
a handful of people and there's no
cameras
right you know I guess when cameras are
around like even though it's so invasive
like a lot of times it makes sense like
okay I'm getting my picture taken like
this is gonna be a moment and I'm gonna
sell out this code okay yeah like a tour
of the milk factory For What and I have
to get all dressed up
no 100 I did find it interesting that
like she was so like
anxious about wearing a similar color to
any of the other senior Royals like she
would always just wear beige or white
and that actually like makes sense
because she was constantly wearing like
a nude palette agreed but I thought that
was intentional because that's like the
style look at my and it's stunning it's
it's stunning and I feel like for the
last few years that's where everything
is trending towards like sad base but on
adults it's not sad and I actually loved
her royal Style
most of it and it made me
they they showed like the sad beige
stuff and then they showed the dress
that she was going to wear to that Gala
it was like orange
was it the big red poofy thing yeah the
big red gooey fish yeah I didn't like it
hate and yeah
hate that's all I'm gonna say
I just honestly and it was like it was
just like that was a weird scene
everyone like watching her try on this
big ugly dressed totally I am now left
with the question of like what
is their life now because like to be
honest and I and I don't mean this in a
negative way like I'm not trying to be
mean because I'm actually like I am a
reformed hater like I'm not a hater
anymore
um I don't really feel like
any of what they do now really provides
value or meaning for their subjects you
know what I mean like I don't really
know what their impact is now like
they're known and and they do like and
they put out you know kids content and
and they go to all these events but
honestly like I don't really know what
what they're doing now yeah anytime they
go to an event I'm just like why are you
there like
on the one hand they're like too big to
go to these small things and on the
other side they're too small to go to
some of these things like that's just
like me walking like or you just walking
into like an army base and like
expecting people to like
drop what they're doing like who cares
it does go without saying like if there
is like a toaster heavy army base I
would absolutely love to come and sing a
few songs for you guys no I no no but
that's a thing that like celebrities
performers entertainers do like the Uso
tours and they go and they entertain our
troops
what are they doing no totally they're
gonna sing
they should that would make more sense
just like what and I'm just like there
to chat
I'm sure that when we want can anybody
just walk onto an army base and try to
like use morale no no you can't be like
hey I'm a magician can I come no we're
like hey I want to talk
to the military
no they'll and then let's do like the
vaccine stuff at the U.N like what
credentials do you have
to make any of this relevant to anyone
by the way even when everyone was out
here promoting the vaccine I don't even
remember them talking about it so no
they were like they were they were going
hard
oh well you know what I think in part
two like we will really find out like
why the idea of them going back is
not no ever that's not even a thing in
part two one at this juncture
to go back no part two we'll find out
why they had to leave
yeah there's no going back and I also
feel like the sit down with Oprah was
much more centered on bashing the family
and I feel like they are changing their
tune a little bit to look at the media
but also Jackie it's important to note
that like allegedly Harry and Megan are
very unhappy with the documentary with
the director specifically
but that's probably just because people
aren't
most of the things that I've seen
written about it are very critical even
from American Media which is so loves
that towards them yeah so I think that's
I don't know what in the documentary
like I would even have had them take out
I think it's just like the way they come
I think it's the fact that there's a
documentary in general like I know you
don't even need to watch it you know
what be like what are you doing and why
are you doing this and like if it's the
media and the Fanfare that you guys hate
then if you lived a smaller life
eventually yeah still people would go
and take your picture and people will
always care about you but you keep
making yourself bigger Stars by doing
all of these things
no and can I tell you that I have a
theory I feel like when they got out of
Dodge
they had you know no idea what their
future held they know they needed like a
big house they needed all this 24 7
security and they signed a bunch of
deals like to the first people who would
ask who would offer and I feel like we
heard about their Netflix deal like
right after they left I feel like they
got themselves a deal almost immediately
just to get paid to live and now they're
like stuck with this thing that they
agreed to do three years ago and that's
why I feel like they're unhappy with the
director
because
why
because they agreed to this thing like
when they were desperate like three
years ago they were leaving or whatever
it was but they couldn't they needed
money they can make anything for Netflix
they have carte blanche it doesn't say
it doesn't are you sure yes like I
haven't read their contract but like
every time the Netflix deal is talked
about it's like kid shows documentary
they're making like Earth type stuff
mental health yeah they can do whatever
they wanted if they said we're not doing
something like this or they could even
do a documentary Harry and Megan and it
followed them on a service tour and we
never you know what I mean like no one
is making them do anything yeah that's
true okay
I just feel like
I feel like at this point American Media
has been very favorable towards them but
like people are getting fatigued by the
constant pleas for privacy while also
putting out a podcast and putting out a
documentary like I think people are
starting to kind of get over them and I
think it would really really behoove
them to take a nice Ariana Grande sized
nap like they need they need a major
break from public life what's crazy is
they've had a major break from public
life like during covid remember we
thought they would be like at the Met
Gala like they there were so many times
where like we expected them to show up
and they didn't and now I feel like it's
a full court press and it's like well
that's not what we want to see expected
and that's not really congress with some
of the complaints that we thought you
guys and also did you see how people are
saying well if you want a privacy why'd
you do a rocky series and now they're
saying like it wasn't about privacy we
never said that
that's what's also so weird to me is
when they left like they said they were
moving to Canada and literally five
minutes later they were in Hollywood
and if you want to live like a smaller
less demanding life like you go to
Hollywood
no by the way Jackie literally Harry
didn't even go to Canada Megan was there
by herself and I think they met in
California like they never no but but
also Devil's Advocate is like California
is also the perfect place to live a
small life because everyone there is
trying to live a small life like they
live in Montecito which is like where
Ellen lives like it's these you know
spacious Estates where everyone is
trying to just like hunker down so like
it is very it is very sceny but it's
also like low-key in a way yeah I guess
I liked the documentary on its own just
watching it but then when I like take it
and apply it to like their actual
actions over the last five years I'm
like
um these are four different people yeah
no totally you know so I'm really I
really am curious to see what the next
three parts holds because still I don't
understand why they absolutely had to
leave why there wasn't a way to make
something work between them and I'm sure
that like the queen would have been
flexible if they were like
we're gonna go live six months here
six months there
we'll see but that scene there was two
things that like stuck out to me won the
Diana not the comparisons but like the
scenes with Diana like as a mom and like
Harry as a baby yeah oh my God I thought
they were like so emotional for some
reason I just like never
I just I don't know it showed like a
time that I'd never seen of all of them
and it was just like so sweet
I agree and I think that like harks back
to what we were saying what I was saying
last week about how sometimes I forget
that Diana was William's mom too yeah um
because Harry and Diana like definitely
had like a special relationship I think
Diana gave him like more attention and
more love because he was like the spare
yeah and so that's what for me that's
what was reflected in the footage but I
think also it's just in their nature
like I think William
is more reserved and Harry is more
emotional like when he said on my
mother's son I'm like yeah and that's
just that's not even you know uh but it
also is perfect because that's the roles
that they're born into and they're each
really suited for it William is suited
to be the heir and Harry is suited to be
like the emotional spare who can take
risks and do what he wants to do
totally
so I'm ready for part two I know but
when are we gonna after three parts
after three parts we still don't like
have get to Meg's it like come on take
longer when does it come out
Thursday night
maybe Thursday maybe we could watch it
Thursday night and recap it Friday
because I would really like to put
finish the year yeah finish the year and
again and know
where we stand
same
just crazy stuff
crazy times are you ready for our next
story
if it's the next story that's brought to
you by Skylight frame
hmm
tis thank you Skylight frame is a photo
frame that you can update instantly by
email from anywhere it's a very special
gift for the special people in your life
so you've got to check out the Skylight
frame it's a great way to feel close to
those you love even when you're
separated it sets up effortlessly in
under 60 seconds just plug it in use the
touchscreen to connect your wireless
network and enjoy sending photos to the
Skylight is effortless everyone in the
family can use the app or just email
them to the Skylight and they'll pop up
in seconds this is such a thoughtful
gift it is the best thing to get for
someone and if you're worried about
someone in your life who's not really
technologically savvy and you want to
get this for them it is so easy to set
up it takes less than a minute even a
non-tech person can do it and then you
can have like a bunch of people in your
life sending photos to Gran or granny
um and it's really special it is uh also
beautiful so it's Timeless it's a black
frame with a white mat so it adds a
beautiful touch to your house the
vibrant touchscreen display lets you
swipe through photos you can even tap to
Heart it and let the person who sent the
photo know that you left it they have
two size options either the original 10
inch or the new large 50 18 inch frame
and they offer 100 satisfaction
guarantee if you don't love your
Skylight they'll offer you a full refund
now as a special offer you can get 15
off your purchase of a skylight frame
when you go to skylightframe.com enter
code toast that's right 15 off your
purchase of a skylight frame when you go
to skylightframe.com enter code toast
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com promo code
toast
great our next story Katie Holmes brings
back the controversial Y2K Trend at
Jingle Ball 2022 so Katie Holmes went
viral this weekend because she wore um a
crazy [ __ ] outfit to Jingle Ball it
included
um the like dress a mini dress like over
a pair of jeans light wash jeans and
boot cut cut and black sneakers and she
as the internet and a tizzy people are
very unhappy with what this might signal
well the thing is is like we're all very
much embracing Y2K style and like Katie
Holmes she took it to take it too far
she took it too far but she also did it
like it's a really poorly executed like
I actually think like the concept of
like a mini dress over jeans like yeah
while it's weird somebody if Done Right
could have like Addison Ray could have
made it cool for a moment Katie Holmes
I'm sorry this is the meanest thing I've
ever said is far too old to be acting
like this first of all second of all the
sneakers the ill-fitting jeans and the
tube top that's like laying weird on her
it's so poorly done
um and I'm sorry she looks like a clown
yeah it's really terrible the sneakers
are for me the worst part and then of
course the jeans I actually really like
the top
um with even just like not trying to
bring back Y2K just like with tights or
or pants I think it would be awesome
um but this is really horrible and I I
think that actually this won't bring
back this trend I think it's like a
cautionary tale and I think Katie Holmes
is actually doing it everyone a service
it's like okay you guys enjoy your
low-rise jeans and like your belly okay
but let's not take this too far it could
end back no I mean I do remember a
moment in time where like Katie Holmes
was like a stylish Queen like she was
living in New York iconic trench coats
like really this elegant classy timeless
style and I don't know how you go from
that to this and I'm I'm actually
concerned about Katie Holmes like I
think I know a cry for help I had like I
genuinely think she got dressed in the
dark I don't think there was a
I don't think there was a stylist
involved or like I should hope not like
laid out two outfits for her one like
the blue top with whatever and then like
a pair of jeans for like no like the
blue top with like a pair of like BBS
and then the jeans with a t-shirt for
the next morning for yeah and she like
got confused and she ran out of the
house and also like why the [ __ ] is
Katie Holmes at Jingle Ball
so that's what I'm saying she also like
went to the wrong event so she got in
the wrong Uber outside of her building
one was for the 14 year old girl who
lives beneath her whose parents are
really rich and who got her like iconic
tickets to Jingle Ball and the other was
to go she should be going like you know
a Gala a restaurant a gallery opening
you know yeah that's what I'm saying
like between the outfit the event the
hair everything Katie Holmes is not okay
Katie Holmes is confused
Katie Holmes is
deeply confused
and so am I but at least she United
everyone in knowing that we just took
this back
no honestly Heather McDonald posted the
funniest thing did you say I saw she
dressed in the outfit and she was like
oh my God literally everyone is copying
me first first Meghan Markle who decides
to start a podcast and move to
California and now Katie Holmes I
literally wear this outfit yesterday
she's it was so funny I think the way
people are reacting to this is like it's
funny and they're not being mean it's
like you know ingest yeah
yeah but I do really like the blue top I
just want to say
I don't it's like it's the least ugly
thing on her but it's by no means like
cute no I think it's pretty like if Ari
was wearing it with like
those big Valentino
Mary Janes and tights
okay
so cute because Ari's shorts would be
like long enough on her
yeah it just looks like one of the slip
dress that like everyone's wearing now
you know Sabrina Carpenter
she would kill it Sabrina Carpenter is
an icon yeah are you ready for our next
story
yeah some crazy news Patti LaBelle was
rushed off stage during a Milwaukee
concert due to a bomb threat
oh my God you see this video
no Patti LaBelle was rushed off stage at
her concert in Milwaukee on Saturday
night amid a bomb scare social media
videos take my audience members at the
Riverside Theater show LaBelle crying as
three men pushed her mic stand away and
got her off stage while she was talking
to the crowd one of the staff members
could be seen grabbing her arm grabbing
her by the arm and forcing her to drop a
bouquet of flowers she was holding as
they escorted her away with no
explanation the singer's band members
quickly followed behind while puzzled
concert goers were heard asking what
happened organizers later confirmed the
show had been halted and ultimately
postponed due to a major security threat
the theater group said that her show has
been postponed following a bomb threat
investigated by the Milwaukee Police
Department after she was removed from
the stage authorities evacuated everyone
else from the theater they're continuing
to investigate the incident per police
statement
hmm
I like someone kind of weird to say
okay
like
the way that like I can't explain tell
me if I'm wrong like
so the band and Patty get escorted
there's a bomb threat and the bomb is
threatening to everyone a bomb will blow
up a building
um and like the people like just sit
there and then they get evacuated like I
don't know what the time between them
leaving the stage and
the crowd being evacuated was like was
it Patty literally goes side stage and
then they're like there's a bomb threat
like they also need to maintain I don't
like I agree they don't want it to be
okay life is more important than the
other but like you don't want Patty up
there being like first of all someone
telling Patty there's a mom thread so
Patty has to tell everyone I'm like
people go into a tizzy like their needs
to maintain some sort of order no some
order no I understand but just like
hearing that being like once Patty was
safe we got everyone else out you know
yeah like she is a celebrity like so I
like and maybe the bomb was like being
thrown at her I don't know yeah but like
it does feel like you're right like no
life is more valuable than the other
because you know you might be famous but
when we're all six feet under we're all
equalizer Flesh and Bones
so that's interesting yeah I hope they
investigate and find out what the [ __ ]
that is the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
it's just great what yeah no that's like
a bomb threat it's like not okay no
so now are you ready for our next story
which is a little more positive musical
news
positive musical news yeah it's PM man
Mean Girls the musical movie cast is
totally fetch see who's playing Regina
Katie and more you guys there's an
upcoming film version based on the
Broadway musical of Mean Girls which is
based on the movie of Mean Girls which
is actually based on a book
is it yeah now that I remember the book
Mean Girls was based on a book called
like something about bees queen bee Mean
Girls how interesting based on queen
bees and wannabes yep
interesting so it was a book turned into
a movie turned into a musical turned
back into a movie musical exactly but
the book queen bees and wannabes is from
2002 it focuses on the ways in which
girls in high schools form clicks and on
patterns of aggressive teenage girl
behavior and how to deal with them so
it's non-fiction
right it's like a psychological like a
it's like a like a science book yeah I
wonder what the actual category is but
that is such like a throwback but that's
so interesting
so I mean Mean Girls the musical was so
popular I didn't see it but like it had
like a cult following
um and that's how we got Renee Rapp
who's in sex lives of college girls
that's how we got Ashley
um who plays what's her name on Emily in
Paris the best friend who's a singer I
think her name is Renee or something no
but I know who you're talking about even
though I watched one so we've got some
like amazing actors out of it yeah well
this film version will star Andrew e
rice Renee Rapp who was in the Broadway
version as Regina she'll be Regina she's
from sex eyes with college girls also
Luli cravalho who sang on Moana
of the soundtrack she was Moana the
voice of her and jackwell Spivey as
Katie
oh no Katie hi Andrew Rice's Katie Renee
rapist Regina alulie cravalho is Janice
and jackwell Spivey is Damien
okay
um I actually like I'm down for this
like I feel like I never saw the musical
and people are obsessed with it and it
was said to be have been really really
good and Renee rap is amazing and I'm
actually like really excited for this
yeah me too now I'm like uh is Tina Fey
involved like was she in I think she was
involved in the Broadway
version she must be yes it will be
written and produced by her and
featuring music from her husband and
lyrics from Nell Benjamin who also
worked on the Broadway musical and SNL
Creator Lauren Michaels is on board as a
producer so there's really no reason why
this should flop
wow literally like Tina Fey stays
milking the Mean Girls cat like she has
made so much money I mean I feel like
Mean Girls at least for me like really
put her on the map
um as like a a serious
not only behind the scenes like and not
the only actor but also behind the
scenes she was like a producer and a
writer um and ever since then like her
career has been like so much different
than like her fellow SNL
Compadres and fellow 30 Rock castmates
and this is just a train that doesn't
stop going yeah it's really crazy then
after this he'll probably be a book
again
and then back to Broadway
yeah
what else could they do with it TV show
yeah
and then they could do
miniseries maybe our kids will yeah like
our kids will have like a different mean
girl and we're gonna be like classic old
moms being like ah you know they're
original with Lindsay Lohan is really
the best one yeah that's like a star is
born there's like a new movie generation
right this is a side star yeah I'm
excited
excitement excites me I'm feeling
feelings of excitement that's great
um and then our fifth and final story is
the name on everyone's lips White Lotus
yes finale last night are you gonna
watch it I am gonna watch it so I will
be unplugging my earbuds while you let
everyone know your thoughts goodbye guys
so the finale was last night we finally
found out who died and I feel like if
you were watching like a lot of theories
on Tick Tock a lot of people had guessed
that Quentin and Greg were like somehow
linked and they were gonna you know kill
her for the money on the prenup now I
just want to say I thought all in all
this was like a good season of a show
when you compared to the first season
where like every character ended up like
being linked in all the story lines made
sense I kind of felt like a little
disappointed in
in who ended up dying I feel like the
way that like that a hotel concierge
ended up dying last time was like so
crazy and random and weird and this one
I don't know it just felt like and the
fact that like she died after is
actually so Tanya because she's like
incapable of doing anything and the fact
that she actually killed those guys and
defended herself is a miracle but her
you know just trying to escape after
everyone's already dead and then like
hitting her head on the edge of the boat
is so Tanya
um I felt like my overall takeaway from
the up from the series was like how much
I [ __ ] hated absolutely everyone most
specifically the Italian Guys you know
what I'm talking about like the ones who
are on a family you know vacation with
the grandpa the dad and the son the son
who ended up giving the hooker fifty
thousand dollars I [ __ ] hated this
man he was such a loser when that hooker
like left him I was so happy because I
was like you know what some lessons
young people need to learn the hard way
and you just got taken by a hooker to
give you her 50 Grand you're a loser so
I love to see that those hookers were
also really bothering me too because
also um I don't know why they had to
wait a whole week to get Theo James to
give them their money like um have you
heard of like venmo or the cash app it
was really frustrating
um but I did like that piano girl like
she helped the hotel concierge like find
her sexuality I thought that was nice
um but overall like I was just hating
everyone like I hated Aubry Plaza and
her [ __ ] husband like I loved Daphne
and her husband but like the other two
like they were so trab and like always
being so negative my God and she's
depressed and then he's depressed and
he's cheating and then she's cheating
like my God shut the [ __ ] up like how
[ __ ] annoying are these people
um so the series was just filled with
like a lot of people I [ __ ] hated I
also hated that girl Isabella like the
front desk concierge I know she had a
minor role but I was just like [ __ ]
hating everyone but I didn't hate Theo
James I didn't hate Daphne I didn't hate
I did take the grandpa from the Italian
family
no I just felt like the first season was
way better I hated [ __ ] Porsche oh my
God I forgot about her because she was
like kidnapped hated [ __ ] Porsche
like what the [ __ ] was that outfit she
was wearing and she ended up wearing it
for like 48 hours straight because that
guy like wouldn't let her go back to the
Palazzo but like that skirt and that
T-shirt and that bag like Jail jail for
you Italian jail for all of you and
that's what you get when you leave the
nice man
for the
Renegade whatever honestly I feel like I
don't even have that many thoughts like
lucky like wasn't that good can everyone
agree or no
that's just me Jax I'm back oh my god
[ __ ] look the [ __ ] up
she's back okay
take longer to put your headphones in
oh wow okay take longer things didn't go
well no they did I do I don't wanna
I don't want to tell you don't Implement
how I feel about it yeah
um so we still have a little TV recap
because I'm all caught up on Yellowstone
I know you have a lot to catch up on
Yellowstone you're all caught up no no
sorry Like I'm made further Headway I
made a Headway you are all caught up on
Yellowstone after two weeks so let's
dive into the TV recap if that's the end
of the stories is it it is the end of
the stories
well TV recap is brought to you by
modern fertility knowledge is power and
when you know more you can make better
decisions for your body your health and
your future there are many big decisions
that there aren't many bigger decisions
than having a kid but for many women
their fertility is a big question mark
but that's why modern fertility was
created an easy and affordable way to
test your fertility hormones at home
with a simple finger prick mail it in
with a prepaid label and you'll get your
results within six days you'll get
insight into your hormone levels like
your ovarian reserve AKA if you have
more fewer eggs in the average woman
your age other important factors that
can impact your fertility the results
will go deep into what every hormone
means and you can also download the
results to review with your doctor for
next steps traditional hormone testing
at a fertility clinic can cost over six
hundred dollars but modern fertility
tests the same general set of hormones
at a fraction of the price and if you go
to modernfertility.com toast30 you can
get 30 off your test plus you can get
reimbursed through your FSA or your HSA
right now modern fertility is offering
our listeners 30 off the test when you
go to modernfertility.com toast30 this
is a limited time offer for 30 off that
means your test will cost 149 hormone
testing at a fertility clinic can cost
three times as much get 30 off your
fertility test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast three zero
that's modernfertility.com toast 30.
today's episode is also brought to you
by the perfect bar don't go nuts this
holiday season fuel yourself with
perfect bar the original refrigerated
protein bar made with freshly ground nut
butter organic honey and 20 organic
superfoods perfect bar has a variety of
products like protein bars and little
snack size bars too that are so good and
good for you you'll be sure to find
something you love my favorite is the
dark chocolate chip peanut butter with
sea salt
with the sea salt perfect bar
um something about dark chocolate in the
fridge with sea salt is like an
Immaculate level of taste and you just
you have to experience it to know you
know it is so delicious and it's
definitely a go-to here at the studio I
keep them in the fridge they have a
cookie dough texture that's creamy and
full of flavor and they're unlike any
other bars out there now they come in
snack size and they're packed with six
grams of proteins and 150 calories a
little will go a long way with these
perfect bar knows that it will be Love
At First Bite so for a limited time
they're offering you a chance to try
their refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
text and upload a picture of your
receipt from your local grocery store
and they'll reimburse you for the cost
of one bar it'll go directly into your
venmo order your PayPal account which is
pretty cool it's pretty cool all you
have to do is go to perfect snacks.com
toast get a free perfect bar today
that's perfect snacks.com toast to get a
free perfect bar today happy snacking
Jax what is your favorite flavor perfect
bar you mean the perfect bar
the perfect bar
um so what's so funny is that last week
I was like oh God that's so surprising
that you like the dark chocolate one and
then I had one for my fridge yesterday
and I remember describing as the ones
that I like as being like cookie dough
but I was like you know what what's the
actual official flavor that I do like so
I could share it next time we were
talking and it's that dark chocolate
peanut butter one so we are so simpatico
because that's each of our favorite
flavors and I wasn't wrong about it
being said My Cookie Dough because that
is the consistency but the dark
chocolate peanut butter one is my go-to
okay so do you want to start with
Yellowstone up-to-date recap and then I
chime in being like an irrelevant ugly
or no let's start in chronological order
with what you watched
so I finished season three last night
and then I immediately watched season
four
um it was the attack of the duttons you
know
Casey got attacked at his office Beth's
office was blown up John Dutton was shot
on the side of the road and big shocker
everyone's alive
um not that I wanted anyone to be dead
but like it's I'm starting to like I can
only suspend disably for so long like
one that people in Montana will just
kill as many people as they want without
ever having any consequences and two
like the duttons are going to
continually get shot and um they're not
gonna die like you know what I mean it's
like a little too convenient
yeah I mean it is a television show but
yeah so now I just want to know on the
whole like how do you feel about the
show Yellowstone like are you obsessed
and in love oh yeah like I went to bed
thinking about it I dreamed about it
um rip dug up his mother's body to get a
ring to give to Beth and I just simply
passed away in that moment I mean it was
like kind of weird how like
like the body was just like green and
like chill in there and then like he
took it off of her and like was talking
to the dead body and like wasn't even
covering his mouth like decomposed
bodies are like literally the most foul
smelling [ __ ] on the planet like
and he was like touching her and he was
like love you Mama like it was sweet but
like a little weird decomposing bodies
yeah like a dead body that's like
freshly dead as it rots it smells bad
but a pile of bones isn't smelly
but it wasn't a pile of bones that's
what I'm saying she was like fully
intact
but like she was embalmed but still you
get smelly
I'm not I literally I could safely say I
don't know
yeah I don't know either gotta ask
Porsha
um
is good and it's good TV you'll like it
in season two it's like oh this is a
really good show but like by season
three her like I would die for this show
I would die for these no I have been
like in love with the show since season
two because Beth and rip like really
were starting there and like they were
sitting on the stars and like they were
being funny I have been obsessed like
since season two and do you love Beth
now because you are being so mean to her
season one I wasn't being mean to her
she was a little much yeah but now but
like I get like it's a necessary evil I
love Beth even though like some of the
[ __ ] that comes out of her mouth is so
wild I love Beth I love rip I I like
John I'm not gonna lie I don't love John
he's like a little
um like negative
I would seriously with my own two hands
kill Jamie
oh my God I watched one episode and I
said he's a good lawyer like literally
you need to get a grip you need to get a
grip
he is such a loser and when I found out
that he was spoiler alert adopted like
everything made sense oh and I did find
out the reason why Beth hates him so
much and I just want to say like
everything she's ever done to him is
completely Justified not enough um it's
not enough he's such an evil Creighton
and he wasn't even apologetic like okay
I understand like you know you were a
kid you were put in a difficult position
like you made a mistake
so you want to apologize like you know
what I actually might have it in my
heart to forgive you
um but the way like you are mad at her
for being mad at you like you're
mentally ill you're not [ __ ] okay
yeah also keep watching season four is a
roller coaster for Jamie
so I also have had a change of heart on
Casey because like I actually found him
to be so [ __ ] annoying and kind of
ugly
now I think he's like kind of hotter
than rip like he's actually like the
strong silent type like I actually think
he's really really handsome and you know
he's starting to see like why this job
is actually perfect for him he loves
being a lifestyle commissioner they just
said to him we want you to run for
governor like he's really meant for this
and of course Monica's bitching and
nagging like a good wife should but I
feel as confident that they'll work it
out I actually really like Casey he's
turning into one of my favorites even
though I didn't even like him in the
beginning and I actually find him like
really attractive like so much so like
maybe even more than rip like
but Rabbi I love his personality like
Casey's personality [ __ ] sucks
they're both handsome you know what I
wouldn't I wouldn't kick either of them
out of bed you know I don't have to yeah
you don't have to choose
I don't have to choose but like I feel
like I'm being disloyal because I've
been such a rip girly and I am a rip
girly but you know don't count out the
Casey you know
yeah Casey solid also as far as we know
like he's really who the
Legacy hinges on so we need him to be
good but then you know John was in the
hospital and Beth finds this like
Twisted teacher boy Wayward kid sitting
on a bench his dad is about to die I
have a heroin and he's like alone in
this world and I'm like oh adopt Tate
will have a friend Beth and rip can have
a child
um and I never heard from that kid again
but I don't think it'll be the last time
we see him but Jamie got that political
hooker pregnant and we never heard from
her again where is she
is she gonna show up with a child you'll
see her again
yeah I mean they there's no way they
would just leave that storyline yeah no
you will see it empty
okay
um so all in all loving the journey
Ben and I I said last week that by today
I'd be finishing all caught up but that
was because I fully intended to move
forward without Ben
but he loves it so much and it's you
know it's actually been a nice thing for
us to have together so for the sake of
my marriage I have decided to wait he
would be so mad okay that's fine I can
be patient is there anything that you
want to like say to me and the or the
the listeners
to you I'd like to say the platform is
not yours you can do your recap and I'll
take my headphones off bye guys
when you guys have been here the whole
time while I begged her to watch I told
her how much she would love it I'm gonna
spend my entire time with her off the
headphones like talking about how
frustrating it is to try and get this
[ __ ] to watch something that I know
she's gonna love
I digress I caught up in the last two
episodes of Yellowstone and what's
interesting is because what Claudia was
just saying how like so much of the show
was unbelievable I feel like we're
getting to a place in the show where
like nothing is happening and I love it
like it's not about the drama it's not
about the storyline or the plot it's
just about like watching characters that
you love and
watching a show that you love and like
the day in the episode last night like
the day in the meadow with the cattle
and like everyone just having the best
day of their lives they like just go off
and chill like what John did napping
literally John napped under a tree Beth
and rip discovered a meadow like these
were the plots and it was so beautiful
and glorious and I really don't need
anything of note to happen on the show
obviously Jamie has other plans for me
with his new wench that he has bedded
and he's so [ __ ] dumb because
obviously she's I think that she's
um
wants to make him Governor wants to oust
John but like she's not going to be ride
or die for Jamie obviously this girl is
like extremely conniving so he's a [ __ ]
he is the villain and it's so crazy one
person will give him like one morsel
of the confidence and say like one nice
thing to him and he is theirs for well
for a minute because he's so [ __ ]
disloyal anyways I thought the episode
on the ranch was just so amazing and
beautiful when that man passed away
under the tree it was like sad but then
it wasn't because
a cowboy couldn't dream of a more
peaceful death
and
that's about it I watched the episode
before I can't remember what happened
Beth and rip are just giving us like
literally everything and we're seriously
not deserving when he had the flask for
her and the cigarettes it was just the
cutest thing and she was like you don't
have to work so hard I'm still gonna
blow you they're just so hysterical the
lines really the lines between them are
getting so great some of the lines on
the writing on the show is like really
so good in some of it you could tell
it's like trying too hard I feel like
sometimes when Beth is being like even
when she was talking this summer it's
just like a little much but I'm glad
that Beth and summer have reached a
Dayton but when John and rip were having
a conversation before the cattle drive
where they like John was saying how the
world is run by cowards it was just so
[ __ ] on point I wish I could have
highlighted it and it was just like how
you know Beth has this instinct to fight
and like
right now like actually strength is not
a symbol of strength it's just like who
can complain and blame like that is the
person who's in a position of power it
was just really interesting so loved it
love our show every season it changes I
feel like last season it was like cowboy
porn even though last night's episode
was Cowboy porn but like this season is
just like characters you love like
really exploring them and not worrying
so much about the storyline in the
airport we're just like having a great
time in Montana
back to Claudia
you're done I'm done
and so are we that is our show a nice
hour and a half long episode oh wow my
memory card's gonna expire I know
um anything else we want to say catch up
on talk about I started um my book for
my book club flicker in the dark which
you read for your book club and everyone
in my book club is listening to the
redheads episode after they finish the
book and what are they saying about our
show
killer killer it really is a killer show
and all I'll say is a little redheads
excitement the final round of redheads
book of the Year voting will start today
on the redhead's Instagram it's reader's
choice we're voting which is the best
book of the year the top three are going
to be lessons in chemistry flicker in
the dark and girls with Bright Futures
three books which you will have read me
clardia oh my God I'm not me feeling
included what would you vote is your
number one well
I liked girls with Bright Futures better
than lessons in chemistry I actually
[ __ ] hated lessons in chemistry now
that I've had some time to think about
how [ __ ] stupid it was
um so now now I just need to finish
Flickr in the dark I'm only 20 through
but I have a feeling my friends in my
book club said that it was amazing I
have a feeling it'll be better than
girls with my Futures but I actually
really liked girls with Bright Futures
try and finish it in time to vote in the
final round make your voice heard okay
uh we'll make my voice heard hashtag get
out the vote don't forget to make a plan
make a plan bring a snack and then head
over to the redheads Instagram to vote
for best book of the year
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast somebody a Morning Show where
until the best I stories you need to
know everybody on YouTube for watching
us on YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as podcast I'm out
of the biggest wedgie
we're also available as a podcast I have
the biggest wedgie
we're also available podcast anywhere
podcasts we found so at Spotify iTunes
Stitcher public radio I have Radio cast
box all the places whoever you listen
podcasts find us the toast and leave a
five-star review about how beautiful
stunning and
talented we are have an amazing Monday
rosengrand and we'll see you tomorrow
bye bye